listen but he didn't find one that's it
it's it's revenge what does this mean
now he's going to now
yes I wanna know haven't you so it's a
Shiite control of dental health even
though it's like yeah I'll do this video
saying he was on drugs
Oh [ __ ] face through it that's not
even a good trick
uh-huh see I kind of thought it looked
fake we are in touch so we're gonna tell
them that justice dude I'm not mad at it
I'm not mad at you can join back on tape
good point they make you famous
taking me super mad at Chris thank you
yes thank you
okay
yeah I probably deserve that a little
bit for everything that's [ __ ] happen
isn't it what they doing the killer took
it
you big buttery huh don't butcher the
banks - man I'm just a sovereign lost
that's a search party because what they
did was [ __ ] you didn't matter
which one just yeah it didn't do
whatever we can do to put up Josh
because I mean if we woke him up
somewhere by himself
this place is not sick no and he knows
he knows the mountain hugging the big
numbers like I would like to keep drugs
or my opinon see girls lend themselves
to such a good plot twist oh I agree the
book that we gonna kill us
me and Mike night you are not shooting
it might look that might even be yeah
see it's not him that my Tracy I believe
it I did yeah I like either of those I
do trust and honor they said I'd do that
for you
well I didn't want to be I didn't want
to aggressive Fred be like dismissive
been aggressive he just need to know
what he did was wrong but he's also
mentally unstable
he's and that's because he's no you do
need which is what you're where's dead
well I mean he [ __ ] don't worry bad
but he didn't hurt anyone though I mean
he kind of led to them being the same
things for us I think that they are
being bullies and I think that they know
that maybe rx the same way you know but
II my traditional period of time than
you'd never go wait time up being honest
what I would be mad at him but
already if this is too much already
so you're single defensive okay no I
don't want any more aggression showing
human defense
every be mad at him yeah every man cook
don't even leave the mountain enough
them leave
don't [ __ ] lock him up by himself no
I'm time and it's enough it's done he's
already been through we're not [ __ ]
and not only his friend and his family's
dead I think it's enough you see this is
dependent events at first I was like
[ __ ] Joffrey now I'm like Hollinger what
does it we always didn't trust John I
was because we always thought it was
weird and completely wrong I only have
the context of knowing that it's
mentally ill because the sisters died
and now I just know it no I'm being
remorseful yes he has a new cos we have
that context and they know too because
you're setting up as myths which is you
need these guys need to just back down
and being nice with you we're not sure
hi what
it's not no hit nothing sounds
dishonored Oh as Kristen is doing
masters yeah I think I thought it was
job as I do sobbing but now you know
he's still he's stupid he's [ __ ] up
but it's yeah he's literally [ __ ] up
he's not you know he's not easy I went
with it as a person no no I think he's
just you think yeah yeah I think he's
just responding so someone's staying
with him that's nice yeah whose resume
sort of please just [ __ ] up good luck
with the pizza here yeah helicopter why
you can come find it funny why I gave
the pizza no you can have whatever you
want or nothing